ce contrat mais mes collègues j'ai pas
d'avis doit-on dire très tranchées
pourquoi parce que c'est quand je suis
allé voir des images que j'ai décidé de
répondre oui mais oui parce que je
considère que dans la manière dont on
produit aujourd'hui le foie gras c'est
pas acceptable de que mme il ya deux
mots qui ont été importants dans ce
débat c'est artisanat et
industrialisation industrie moi je
trouve que le mal de notre de notre
société pas que dans ce domaine
en général c'est de manquer de
régulation en fait on est passé dans le
tout industriel notamment dans les
questions agroalimentaire on en a oublié
tout ce qui en faisait les notions de
terroir les notions je veux dire un peu
traditionnelle et autres pourquoi
simplement pour des questions
économiques
or moi je réponds oui parce que le
gavage industriels je peux pas
l'accepter je peux pas le tolérer le
bien-être animal prend le dessus dans
mon esprit
dans ma conception des choses après
quand je dis que j'ai pas un avis
tranché que je vais pas satisfaire mon
voisin c'est vrai que si on à rester au
stade artisanal potentiellement je
pourrais dire non il faut pas arrêter la
production
parce que en fait je trouve qu'on mange
trop de viande dans notre société
donc même dans les abattoirs je trouve
qu'on abat trop on n'a pas trop de
viande en manger trop de viande hommage
en plus mal on nous fournit des
conneries donc il faut qu'on revienne à
plusieurs régulation plus de raison donc
si on avait un consensus possible entre
flux bien être animal globalement
respectée et effectivement des
traditions qui sont là donc on n'a pas
envie vraiment de se séparer le sud
ouest c'est le foie gras connu dans le
monde entier
la france est le plus au premier
producteur au monde c'est ce qui fait
aussi partie de notre rayonnement
d'occidentaux patrimoine gastronomique
met un l'état
je dis non en l'état ça peut pas être
acceptable on a 22 pays sur 27 au sein
de l'union européenne qui interdit la
production de foie gras parce qu'il fait
le garage de que parce que ça n'était
pas acceptable tel qu'on le fait le
gavage
il ya des pays comme l'argentine ya des
pays comme l'inde il ya des pays comme
l'australie comme la friche de cuivre
elle qui était une des plus gros
producteurs héros
nu sur logan il ya bien une raison mais
il faut un moment donné qu'on se parle
tranquillement et qu'on essaie de
trouver entre eux deux
c'est pas tout blanc ou tout noir vous
êtes un artisan j'ai presque envie de
vous dire vous ne dérangez pas dans ce
que vous faites un industriel va me
déranger parce que quand il ya 68 66
mignonne de canoteurs 66 minutes quand
j'ai vu ce chiffre
et quant au moins les images de l214 je
dis non c'est pas possible on n'est pas
raisonnable on fait n'importe quoi si on
en prend quelques centaines de milliers
on peut dire bon pourquoi pas il ya la
tradition et c'est pas dégueulasse et
autres mais globalement respecte les
animaux pour ça que c'est vrai que on
nous propose répondent par oui ou par
non c'est pas blanc ou noir la vie c'est
plus compliqué que ça j'essaie de
trouver un entre-deux raisonnable qui
permettent effectivement à chacun de s'y
retrouver en respectant les animaux
c'est pas simple mais j'ose dire qu'un
moment donné j'ai pas un avis hyper
trash et j'ose le dire
alors il écoute votre avec intérêt mais
le messie de le gavage que vous avez vue
industriel là qui date de quelques
années ça c'est complètement interdite
aujourd'hui même la production
industrielle donc ont remis de l'ordre
donc dans la maison un petit poème on
sollicite trop d'animaux 2000
je voudrais dire autre chose c'est que
ce que vous avez dit c'est quand même
très intéressant quand même parce que on
est passé si vous voulez donc d'une
société rurale à une société urbaine
aujourd'hui la majorité des gens vivent
dans les grandes villes exemple ici qui
c'est qui a vu donc des canards dans le
champ quoi peu de peut déjà un clou mois
sur les champs elysées que la terreur à
chez foot locker j'en ai pas vu voilà
oui mais c'est justement ça c'est à dire
que dans la société rurale à 1950 n'y a
pas de frigo en acheter des poules
vivantes les poulets vivants et les
canadiens de marché on l'y ramener à la
maison les saignées soi même et on les a
ratées soi même on l'évité soi même et
tout ça aujourd'hui c'est fait par des
usines à poulet c'est vrai quoi
et donc pourquoi parce qu'il ya le
système que vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure donc le système de la dictature
du prix par le supermarché amène donc
rien à produire et des salades et des
poulets et des concombres de façon des
fois des riverains soyez d'accord pour
connu une production moindre en nombre
mais plus qualitative
allez vous serez d'accord va vous dire
oui il n'a pas précisé sur pas s'il
voulait dormir il faut mettre un terme à
l'ère du jeu
je suis désolé mais je veux finir mon
petit con excusez moi monsieur cyril je
veux finir mon propos c'est très
important ce que je voulais vous dire
cette société rurale donc aujourd'hui
elle a basculé la révolution
industrielle
et bien c'est fait dans les années 50 60
ans et à sa maman donc maintenant
l'information qu'ont les gens c'est par
le biais de la télévision
vous imaginez ce soir le débat quoi les
gens ils vont avoir une formation comme
ça ou par internet
la manipulation d'internet ou la
manipulation donc suivant les
journalistes qu'on va avoir donc
l'approvisionnement c'est le supermarché
il ya des gamins qui l'ont jamais vu ça
et quand on leur donne tu es tu va
bouter du lapin on lui dit mais et c'est
bon le la paix mais le la sphère regarde
il est là il est vivant et il est très
très gentil et alors ils comprennent pas
qu'au moment donné il faut tuer le lapin
pour pouvoir alors il fait de manger
il ya une rupture entre la société
rurale et la société urbaine
alors elle a que vous dites la vérité
lequel est produit aujourd'hui ça vous
dirait la produise a dit mme bien oui
elle nous a réagi l'un des shows ps
aurait dû des chemins fermés
voilà il en a qualité ce sera donc une
agriculture bio et donc le respect des
animaux le respect de la terre d'un
environnement quoi